[Music]
[Laughter]
this is this episode of congratulations
is brought to you by the cash shop you
already know the cash app is the number
one app in finance but did you realize
you can get the most powerful debit card
in the world with the cash apps cash
card just select a boost in your cash
app swipe the cash card and save 10% or
more at Whole Foods Shake Shack Chipotle
Taco Bell chick-fil-a and all coffee
shops around the country we'll talk
about this more later on in the show so
sit on the edge of your seat
download the cash app for free on the
App Store or Google Play market there
you go those were all the [ __ ] those
key chains are for all the [ __ ] Road
dates I just did I was in where the
where was I look first of all welcome
episode 106 of congratulations thought
was gonna do three episodes and then
quit and here I am a hundred and three
episodes later so it's a hundred and six
you guys are a great audience and thanks
for listening I just got back from the
Midwest and had a good time it was way
too cold well was it too cold yeah was
it less than zero degrees yes no should
all those people relocate yes
are they going to no do they say they're
going to yes are they going to know that
I'm going to but they should it's way
too cold I was in Milwaukee Madison and
Chicago and when I was in Madison it was
negative six when I was in Milwaukee it
was ten ten degrees and then when I was
in Chicago was like 42 look you know
what's the most annoying thing is the
guy who goes who goes like this who
after they [ __ ] after it's real cold
like negative six and the ten degree
weather everyone's going like this oh
it's a [ __ ] balmy it's all what is it
practically summer
that's amazing hey guy you're boring get
a personality
don't just say stuff you see here you
know I'm talking about
don't just say stuff you hear that's
that's as funny as saying see you next
year on December 30th but anyway that's
what he did alas that's what he did
and I heard people saying that and but
it was all good man we had a good time
it was it was absolutely [ __ ]
freezing I don't get how people can do
that and also like cold is cold some
people will be like hey I don't even
feel it anymore like yeah I don't
believe that cold is cold I don't care
if you're from there it sucks
how cold it is it's a great place
Madison is an awesome place Milwaukee
was great the theater in Milwaukee was
awesome what do you call it what did I
do the Riverside Theatre a really great
theater and then I did Chicago theater
which was the biggest show that I've
done so far solo really until my Phoenix
one which will be even bigger and then
my other Chicago ones also so if you I
have two more Chicago's coming up
because popular demand I sold out the
first two in a day and each and then the
third one is up for sale now and there's
still some tickets left so if you want
to get them get them now because it will
sell out but yeah and the [ __ ] by the
way the funniest thing happened in
Chicago that ever was on the road with
me and my opener so my opener is my
opener is is this my headphones not
working what is this dude why does this
keep happening can you hear me
you can hear me okay my opener is good
yeah I mean I hear me now my opener is
he like a lot of people are starting to
know who he is
my shows because I post about him on
Instagram I talk about him on podcast
regret it yes but he's basically a dog
in human form like they don't have to
cast [ __ ] you know in the movies
where dogs talk and stuff they don't
have to they should literally just put
him in it
and not do any CGI and just have him
talking that's how he is and he would be
with other dogs and you'd be like
someone's worried about that other dog
and be like oh it's actually a human he
I go yeah I see it actually so he since
people are starting to get to know who
he is at my show specifically and
strictly and not anywhere else just so
he knows just so he doesn't get a
[ __ ] big ego he he's he also does
these stupid videos where he'll he'll
like put a movie together for the
weekend and it's all you know it's like
he'll be he'll overlap some like stupid
music that's like the boys I'm back in
town or like Danny Danon thang-thang or
like the iPhone song that everyone has
think the thing to think that the thing
to whatever sound someone's [ __ ] like
that anyway whole lay it he'll lay it
over and he'll do like a horribly cut
together [ __ ] thing that only like a
girl he was dating would like and so he
was shooting one getting footage
quote-unquote as he calls it for the
Chicago show cuz it was a big show and
he put his hood up so people wouldn't
recognize him in the audience and then
he would go so what he did we went out
in the audience went to the back of the
room and he wanted to get like this
tracking shot where he's walking all the
way up to the stage and he had his hood
up and when he did it he got all the way
up to the stage and he thought in his
dumb [ __ ] brain instead of going
around to the side and going back
outside and then downstairs and back
upstairs to the back of the state to the
back greenroom
he was like I'm just gonna hop the stage
so he went to hop the stage and [ __ ]
six security guys tackled him doing
their job and he was they were like what
the [ __ ] are you doing you can't do that
and he was like no I'm opener on the
opener screaming out on the opener in
front of everybody the show was gonna
start in ten minutes how can you be that
[ __ ] stupid
said with love I mean it's my show I
wouldn't expect security didn't know who
I was I would walk up to security be
like just so you know I'm doing this you
guys
I was I was like dude that's the dumb
you're I was like of all the things
you've ever done on the road that's the
dumbest thing you've ever done he was
even he was like yeah I know I was
really stupid he got beat up practically
ah Wow
I should have walked out right there and
just been like you're fired
and everyone's like oh no and it's weird
and then I did the show solo how I just
like he's a dog he's a dog in human form
and that's it and that's final and
that's final
I mean it as a kid we would say that me
my brother I'm not doing it and that's
final
like and then we were and then the other
person was like [ __ ] we can't convince
him now that's final not [ __ ] as if any
other times we didn't say it's final it
wasn't final you could change our mind
but if we said his final can't change
our mind anyway
I so Chicago was awesome they were all
awesome they're not really not awesome
anymore you know you go out there you do
the shows the fans are ready they're
psyched to see you I was it had been two
years to the day that I had been to
Chicago doing a show and that so that's
pretty cool I always like cool kind of
like serendipitous or whatever not
certain Dippet us but like facts like
that where it's like it was two years
ago to the day and then I signed the
wall next to [ __ ] Lauryn Hill David
Copperfield
signed the wall on Chicago theater the
magic of David Copperfield and I was
thought about it for a little bit I was
like that's [ __ ] hilarious cuz they
also drew a huge picture taken up a real
estate big ego
and Lauryn Hill had a huge thing too
that she I don't know if these artists
come with like big ass stamps or some
[ __ ] they're [ __ ] huge KD Lang had
like a [ __ ] it's like
Frank Sinatra just went Frank Sinatra
thanks guys and then probably [ __ ]
[ __ ] a hooker you know I just wrote
Chris D'Elia
than the date and then I write my name
always afterwards
in not cursive some people know it's me
cuz people just go like and you're like
who's that and someone's like it's Bruce
Willis and like why the [ __ ] was Bruce
Willis here what was doing a [ __ ] live
a live version of die hard crawling over
the glass center or theaters like hey
all these [ __ ] guys got bands though
Bruce Willis has a band you know Brazil
is a band that's one thing I'll never
have is a serious band mark my [ __ ]
words if I ever ever serious band shoot
me with a bow and arrow serious bands
wait but what was I saying so I signed
it and oh and then the magic of David
Copperfield and I thought about it for a
little bit I was like damn dude like we
all know magic isn't real you know like
everybody straight-up knows that just
straight-up everybody knows that
everybody knows that more than everyone
who knows that wrestling is fake and a
lot of people know wrestling is fake
okay so the fact that like a 50 year old
man would would would sign a wall the
magic of me like can you wrap your head
around what it might be like to be that
person like to be 50 and be like like is
either he thinks it's magic which he
doesn't or he thinks I'm just gonna do
this because people know magic isn't
real but they like the idea of magic or
what is it do it magicians
have to have the biggest egos right how
about them [ __ ] some of them are
cooled like the funny ones are cool like
my buddy Justin who has got that special
on Netflix he's dealt but the funny ones
are cool and then also the ones like
David Blaine are cool because like
they're not really doing magic they're
just like standing on a pole in a square
for a day and a half and you're like
how's he do that without eating doesn't
he piss and you're like it's more of a
[ __ ] stunt you know but um anyway the
magic of David Copperfield yeah so I
signed up with somebody but they have
they had a plexiglass thing over Frank
Sinatra's signature which was pretty
cool that's crazy that Sinatra would
just [ __ ] Wow imagine getting to see
four if you if you could go back in time
what time would you go back I want to
say like I would go way back I would
want to see like dinosaurs or some [ __ ]
but like I think I might go back to just
for me I might just go back to like the
80s or to see to be my age now and to go
to the comedy store and like see those
guys are like Pryor and Eddie Murphy and
to see those guys I might do that or go
see dinosaurs or go to like see what
Napoleon's really like you know I mean
just to see how [ __ ] they were like
kings and queens I might go back in time
to see how [ __ ] Kings were I mean Kings
were the biggest [ __ ] there before
could still are you know what I mean to
put the or like anybody who wore like a
[ __ ] fancy wig or like powdered their
face like or put on those fake beakers I
used to call them beakers but they're
[ __ ] beauty marks what the [ __ ] I'm
sure those people smelled like [ __ ] dude
imagine how bad a [ __ ] King smelled
for real imagine
how bad a [ __ ] King smelled just with
gout just like [ __ ] farting and [ __ ]
and I bet Kings [ __ ] in their [ __ ]
Royal garb all the time
and they would like they would be like
clean it up serve and get my bath ready
next week
fat [ __ ] Kings was there like you're
either a fat [ __ ] King or a [ __ ]
skinny-ass [ __ ] King nobody would
listen with skinny King you gotta be a
fat King otherwise nobody's like if
you're a skinny King and like the
[ __ ] 1400s would be like well why is
he not eating why does he look like that
why is he as skinny as [ __ ] rami
malek I want my king fat as [ __ ] shirt
why they just this king right here who
is that just some random king that we
found our work of why is he dressed like
[ __ ] Jared Leto going to dinner Jared
Leto what are you dressing like bro I I
want to thank Jared Leto is cool but
he's just like I don't know that's not
cool to me it's quick like his outfits
would be like here's the thing man if
Liam Neeson dressed like Jared Leto I
would think it was [ __ ] bonkers cool
or Bruce Willis if he dressed like Jared
Leto bonkers cool or who else I don't
know like skinny ass [ __ ] it's
tough for me to think they're cool is
that [ __ ] prejudice yeah it is it's
like if you could put some weight on I
guess is what I'm saying before you're
[ __ ] cool if I could like break you in
half just beef
some sort of fit and he probably has fit
but like what are you doing wearing I
got maybe I'm just jealous
I got a wear [ __ ] like that [ __ ] I got a
wear [ __ ] like that I really do I'm not
famous enough though that's the thing I
need to get SuperDuper famous to where I
can wear like a [ __ ] Dodge Neon
like literally wear like parts of a
Dodge Neon and it's just all heavy and
[ __ ] just clunking it all around at like
some terrible [ __ ] Hulu premiere that
I'm not even in and he's just like oh
here comes Chris D'Elia he's wearing a
Dodge parts of a Dodge Neon Wow and his
midsection and [ __ ] is exposed very
interesting okay very cool what are you
here for I don't know I just figured I
wanted to just wanted to see it just
wanted to see it even though Netflix
already made a movie about this and Hulu
is making it a week later I'm still I'm
at the premiere dressed like a Dodge
Neon I'm a [ __ ] out that but see if I
did that now people will be like [ __ ]
this guy who's he think he is I need to
get to be the number one comedian or the
number five actor you know and just get
parts of a Dodge Neon and just start
wearing it and so where nobody would say
[ __ ] and girls would just be like wait a
minute
that's [ __ ] he pulls it off she
actually pulls it off and then some part
of their hate or [ __ ] boyfriend would
be like but what he's got a [ __ ] and
that he's got a [ __ ] muffler coming
out of a side of his ass and they'd be
like yeah but he pulls it off it's gonna
burn his ass if he turns it on right
whatever you're just tell us you can't
wear a Dodge Neon parts of a Dodge Neon
at a Hulu premiere that's all right you
know III just yeah he looks like a
[ __ ] transformer though right people
from Boston with their accent chicks
from Boston with that accent you know
hey now for nothing
Masaki dick doh hey not for nothing you
guys wanna go see what's up with those
[ __ ] bridesmaid dresses see if
they're ready or whatever hey where the
[ __ ] we're gonna Park over here we got
to get the [ __ ] pizza Hey
hey [ __ ] come here we're going to get
some [ __ ] pizza
hey nice ring well you getting when you
get married huh you got a date yeah
[ __ ] hey did you suck his [ __ ] [ __ ]
last night oh you got to get a [ __ ]
guy right look at your [ __ ] tits in
that dress all falling out what are you
doing what are you trying to get a
[ __ ] guy you're a thought yeah
[ __ ] get in the car come on let's go
let's go get some [ __ ] let's go get
some quinoa we got to watch our figures
right let's go get some [ __ ] quinoa
sweet greens hey you go sucking [ __ ]
last night we all went out with hey what
happened to [ __ ] Rachel hey Rachel
yeah what's happening hey did you suck
[ __ ] [ __ ] last night
nah now I wasn't really feeling it man
yeah why not
oh you know he made me scared for my
safety yeah why hey you know when you
get alone in the room with a man they
could [ __ ] kill you yeah that's true
like still [ __ ] kind of feminine but
the way they sound isn't yeah I couldn't
wait to get my [ __ ] heels off you
know couldn't wait to get in my [ __ ]
good lounging outfit right yeah yeah
that's right
[ __ ] these guys don't know what it's
like to wear some [ __ ] heels Jesus
Christ I got [ __ ] blisters the size
of my [ __ ] areolas really wanted to
suck his [ __ ] just to figure I make him
wait more I don't want him to think I'm
a [ __ ] thought um huh I don't even
know how I started talking about that
but whatever oh oh by the way [ __ ]
I don't DirecTV showed up dude they
[ __ ] straight-up showed up DIRECTV
part two they showed the [ __ ] up with
three guys that weren't dressed in
uniforms where they were wearing
sweaters and I swear to god they look
like they were in a j.crew catalog ah
and they did everything and then left
which lets me know you can do it they
tear it up texted me dude I got a
[ __ ] like I'm gonna have a lunch with
him I am dude I told him I would take
out Hulu if they didn't show up I told
him I would take out Hulu take out the
dish employees and [ __ ] and take them
to dinner and then make love to him I'm
not gonna do that anymore they came and
they said [ __ ] up which means they can
do it they got scared dude they got
scared because of the [ __ ] cult see
that's what we're doing here we're
bettering lives and not just mine we're
making DirecTV sit back and think the
cult made direct TV sit back reflect on
how the [ __ ] their customer service was
running and it was running poorly and I
had to put out a [ __ ] hot freestyle
about it and it was a wake-up call for
them and I don't just want it to work
with me I want it to work with everyone
else so we are bettering the world
babies babies we are better in customer
service and we are bettering the world
thank God I didn't have to suck their
clock huh take him out to dinner
um how about how good [ __ ] Christian
Bale is in that movie the fighter at the
end when they just do that one clip and
he's just talking and he's just like
yeah you know and he's just goes huh and
he starts crying what the [ __ ] hey are
you really that guy I would only like
Christian Bale better for if there was
one other thing he did if he didn't
[ __ ] either lose weight or get fat or
use prosthetics and was just like this
is how I'm doing it I want I need
Christian Bale I need you to play a
[ __ ] Indian woman with no makeup
and just kill it and get nominated I
think that rami malek it's malik right
I think he's that guy I saw a little bit
on the plane I saw Bohemian Rhapsody
he's so good in that movie that guy is
so good I saw him once at the coffee
bean and and I was like am i famous
enough to where he's gonna know who I am
and I went hey man I'm a fan of your
work he said oh yeah I know you yeah
you're really great I like your stuff
yeah you're really funny I was like oh
cool thanks buddy he was like yeah yeah
[Music]
anyway but he [ __ ] killed that [ __ ]
he killed it with his [ __ ] buck ass
prosthetic teeth dude I need to get some
[ __ ] bug ass prosthetic teeth and
just [ __ ] you would roll that [ __ ]
made me want to get some buck ass
prosthetic teeth I was crazy Bohemian
Rhapsody
dude Freddie Mercury was this [ __ ] but
wasn't he tall
I feel like Rami Lu is shorter how tall
is uh what's his name five nine five
nine Freddie Mercury Romney's five nine
tall is Freddie Mercury five ten oh okay
he looks big in the old [ __ ] god that
guy rocked it though damn I want to
that's honestly wow that's a see that's
how I got a dress just in a [ __ ]
crown and a wife-beater
you know like such a mixed up [ __ ]
outfit a crown and a wife-beater
or a [ __ ] rep did you see what was
his name Travis Scott was that was at
the Super Bowl
he is belt oh my god it was a little bit
tom belt and it was just like you were
just like relax bro it you literally it
was a pillow it was a [ __ ] pillow you
could sleep on and have a great great
nine hours sleep on like it was [ __ ]
felt and it was like something that some
[ __ ] [ __ ] in the eighth grade
would make an art class and everyone be
like wow that's the best one you'd be
like no it's not look at my finger print
[ __ ] you [ __ ] yeah some guy hit me up
in mediums I was making fun of the song
sicko mode and somebody hit me up at the
DM is like dude if you have to actually
look at it on rap genius it's the lyrics
are really deep and I did and no they're
not you know he says Jamba Juice any
song where the guy says Jamba Juice it's
not deep that's like when DMX had made
that song where he's like the [ __ ] and
the lawnmower is next to the tree and
you're like okay well you're done and
the lawnmower is right next to the tree
okay all right now you're just telling
me where you put your [ __ ] chore
stuff paper clips are on a desk and if
you need envelopes there next to the
paper clips
remember when DMX would just do that
[ __ ] intros and outros you know like
I know the blackout bar knows coming to
like over I know hey man not Robert
Frost
DMX what is it the [ __ ] X gon give it
to ya you know but dude we're the hood
at who we be I mean these [ __ ] songs
dude I think it's the who we be through
he doesn't long long or right next to
the tree let me just Google DMX lawn
mower I mean it comes up you know
here we go this is it came down to earth
[Music]
listing things a list a list my keys my
hat a brother a mother existed
[Music]
ah a brother a sister computer a hat dr.
Seuss a brother a sister computer ahead
coffee
a phone a rug a cat a bet a ding on the
wall a roof oh ho
the lawnmower sitting right next to the
tree they don't know who we be ah what a
case for your headphones tile a case for
their phones tile a plant and a plug and
outlet you put it in outlet a rug a plug
don't know from a beard your eyes your
face he knows your face your face you
knows what favorite rap song of all time
just clinched it just clinched it dude
music is [ __ ] hilarious dude unless
you're singing like queen drop it for
real when Queen is just like [ __ ] and
we are the champions and they key and
they're just saying see if they were
like the lawn mowers right next to the
tree you'd be like I believe it awful
dude I would [ __ ] oh yo and no
[ __ ] if Queen had a song like that I
would [ __ ] goddamn it
I just [ __ ] Pay Pal whoever has the
estate to Queen I just PayPal them money
every month
um I mean dude that's so [ __ ] unless
you're doing it like that just kid I
mean oh the two types of music to do are
the killer [ __ ] like that where you got
an amazing voice and you're singing
about how you're the champion ha ha
that's awesome or this kind of music
there is no more guy I'd rather be in a
room with than this [ __ ] then this
[ __ ] song this song okay
there is a right here well first of all
there's this song the fun uncle the fun
annoying are the unknown the fun uncle
that you like when you're six and then
when you turn 14 you're like [ __ ]
uncle scatman isn't coming is he dude
this guy what ha ha ha you know what I
mean dude come on bro dude what a
[ __ ] [ __ ] dude this guy let me tell
you too also here we go
scatman there's the there's the song I
mean I would love to be in a room with
this guy Jesus Christ dude uh what's the
[ __ ] there's one song that it did the
guy is so [ __ ] high what's it called
it's on that track scat man man album I
got I gotta find this for you guys ok ok
it's this one scat man's world
I think hey yeah this is it here we go
dude you're so high
I mean don't need an intro for this cat
man's world that's not a place juice oh
my god dude I'm telling you right now
[Music]
scat man fat man black and white and
brown man dude people from [ __ ]
Eastern Europe like literally they love
this music so much it's unbelievable I
bet damn dude
that's so there's there's another one
though what's the [ __ ] one I used to
have it because it was so funny dude let
me do the were the ads here and then
I'll [ __ ] do it okay I'll find it
blue apron oh man I cooked blue apron
laughs like two weeks ago and it was so
good man
create healthy habits this year by
learning to cook at home blue apron
offers a variety of meals including
kid-approved family plans vegetarian
plans and their brand new WWE freestyle
plan whoo Aven really gives a better way
to cook chef designed recipes that use
fresh seasonally inspired ingredients
meals worth sharing on social media in
as little as 20 minutes time-saving tips
and techniques as I go upcoming meals
pork chorizo burgers and roasted
potatoes
spicy soy glazed chicken thighs the
website and the mobile app make it
really easy to plan the meals each week
and each meal comes with an
easy-to-follow recipe and perfectly
portioned ingredients it's really really
good I made like this chickpea quinoa
thing with it and egg in it the other
day ate at all it was for two people ate
all of it check out this week's menu and
get $60 off at blue apron Dom sauce
Congrats that's blue apron comstock
Congrats blue apron a better way to cook
Robin Hood so I got I've signed up for
Robin Hood and I got some stocks on
Robin Hood and what it is is an
investing app that lets you buy and sell
stocks ETFs options and Kryptos all
commission-free they strive to make
Financial Services work for everyone not
just the wealthy non-intimidating wave
for stock market newcomers to invest for
the first time with true confidence
simple and intuitive clear design with
data presented in and easy to digest way
now if I can do it then it's doable
trust me I did it very easily I bought
some stocks and I mean it was literally
the easiest thing and then I watch them
I watch them on my phone and they make
it really I mean it's the easiest thing
if I can do it you could do it other
brokerages charge up to $10 for every
trade but Robin Hood doesn't charge
Commission fees straight trade stocks
and keep all of your profits so I mean
it's a no-brainer Robin Hood web
platform also lets you view stock
collections entertainment and social
media and curate there's there's
collections like entertainment and
social media and curated categories like
female CEOs and analyst ratings of I
hold cell for every stock learn by doing
I did it you can too Robin Hood is
giving listeners a free stock like Apple
Ford or sprint to help build your
portfolio
sign up at Congrats Robin Hood calm
that's Congrats Robin Hood calm cash out
the cash app team and I recently spoke
about trying something new during this
segment however that was late this
Friday and their copywriters had already
gone home when I asked what I could do
in the meantime they suggested and I'm
quoting that I read a list of some
favorite foods okay so
here it goes these are some of my
favorite foods tuna chicken quinoa eggs
meatballs love meatballs spaghetti
obviously with the meatballs ice cream
sandwiches you know I like them pizza
tomatoes and coffee can't chew coffee
but it counts to me
download the cash app from the App Store
or Google Play Store then get the cash
card and start saving 10% or more every
single time you swipe dip or tap at
Whole Foods
Chipotle Shake Shack chick-fil-a talk
about Duncan Starbucks local coffee
shops and more see see how many that is
and of course when you download the cash
app and enter the referral code congrats
you'll receive $5 and the cash app will
send $5 to the times up Legal Defense
Fund so go do that now I gotta find this
song by the way of for from scatman it
was on the album scat man's world scat
man's world on track listing tracks here
song of Scotland was that it I mean that
everything is Scotland with this guy
deaf this is it
this is where he really [ __ ] lost his
mind
[Music]
okay
but have time to
where everybody is equal and we're all
telling truth
the Society of Scotland is composed of
very loving caring people who have never
even heard a political corruption a
class distinction the war and all the
other stuff that goes on 0:01 is equal
in Scanlan okay really driving that
point home then there's a bunch of kids
singing
oh my god dude imagine slitting your
wrists of this song magic is laying in a
tub just like that's it here we go song
it and then just be like this imagine
that and you don't die yet no you don't
imagine you don't die yet and then it
shows all of a sudden you're on your
Apple phone and then and then and you
die to this song I will be pissed I'd be
like Oh for [ __ ] sake no somebody
change it and then just oh and then
someone finds you with this what if
somebody finds you and it goes to this
this is not him but dude I mean I can't
do when I was a kid I loved that song so
much don't do worry be happy I'm talking
too much about music anyway that guy is
probably the best uncle until you're
[ __ ] 13 and then you hate him
also yeah I mean it has so many demons
you know - [ __ ] made-up
that's that guy's kind of my hero to
make up a [ __ ] dream world and then
just make seven albums about it scat
world okay it's nothing also doesn't
mean [ __ ] on people cool it's a
German yeah we listen to Scott world but
it means something so different to us we
love listening to it and [ __ ] all
over our spouses we love listening to
Scott men and [ __ ] all over our
spouses hey what's a [ __ ] German lady
named German German lady named names
here we go like hit Emma Amelia Anna
these are not good ones Wolfgang you
know that's good for guys come on I
don't hide there's a good German name I
don't hide come in here what what
Wolfgang Idol hide get in here come here
come here [ __ ]
[Music]
come here [ __ ] you know this [ __ ]
hey Idol Hey oh no no no Wolfgang come
here I don't hate let me see your chest
Kevin what am I talking about all right
dude that's [ __ ] gross you know uh my
buddy got punched dude he got beat up in
in he was singing karaoke and then he
got [ __ ] they put he sang his song
and then put the thing back in the
microphone and then just some guy just
[ __ ] beat him up and then ran and
then ran into a car and left and he has
no idea why and he has no idea who did
it and that's it that's just filled his
life now how [ __ ] crazy is that
doesn't know who he is and damn god damn
I was like did you do anything you bump
in anybody did you look at anybody weird
he was like nope it's just some guy just
beat the [ __ ] out of him [ __ ] crazy
right you know what I do that's it for
that you know what I do I get so much
[ __ ] sleep and I'll get the mostly if
I ever want but by the way dude my
[ __ ] tour manager Zach sleeps so
[ __ ] much it's unreal it's unreal
dude he'll be sleeping at night wake up
we'll drive to the next city in the car
he sleeps the whole way he'll get there
he'll get to the hotel he'll sleep in
the [ __ ] hotel room then we'll go do
our show and then he'll go back and
we'll hang out for a little bit and then
he'll be like hey one of the girls
recognized me from your podcast did it I
got her a number and then he'll go to
sleep I was texting her but then I fell
asleep Hey and he was like he likes to
go in
reduce the show sometimes like he likes
to go out on stage and be like you guys
ready you might know me from Chris's
podcast I'm Zack and then he'll do the
laughs but he'll make the lat is like
just do your regular laugh but they
don't like try to do the laugh and then
people are like okay is that it and then
I'll be like okay hey
and then and then he brings a mic
onstage but like people like not
everybody listens to the podcast on the
show the mama shows so people are like
who's that [ __ ] guy that with the
high hat dude he's got the highest ass
his ass is in his shoulders he takes a
[ __ ] like this this is how he takes a
[ __ ] like this
hey don't BOTS don't worry don't hey
don't worry about me I'm just digging
the [ __ ] out of my shoulder blades day
hey dude his ass is so high even black
guys are like damn that's a high [ __ ]
ass dude his ass is so high he is how he
wipes it that's how he wipes his ass
this is how he farts look he does how he
does a silent one so it does it if he's
in public and it is like this this how
he doesn't slide the one to let it out
you know when you spread your cheeks my
ass is so my [ __ ] so high that my
balls should be on my chest a minut
everywhere my [ __ ] should be my face is
all the way up done Co V oh you know
it's Italian
he's so Italian he should be eating a
pizza all the time dude [ __ ] out of
his shoulder blades Oh bro I [ __ ] love
life man how come everybody isn't
laughing all the time some people don't
laugh that much dude people that just
always talk business and [ __ ] god those
people are boring
or politics dude in scat world people
don't even know about political
corruption I'll go to scat world is that
with a [ __ ]
let me unzip my shoulders all he does is
[ __ ] eat candy [ __ ] and sleep I swear
and shower dude he takes nine showers a
day
the [ __ ] dude
anyway you're gonna get me laid from
your podcast easy dude
what's more depressing than getting laid
from a [ __ ] podcast episode Oh God
you weren't on foot you didn't have an
arc on Game of Thrones you know what are
you in [ __ ] the E Street Band is that
the name of it how about one big bands
go like this and they [ __ ] sing and
they [ __ ] share a microphone get your
own [ __ ] microphone dude if I was the
lead singer and the [ __ ] second
guitarist or the lead guitarist start to
[ __ ] dip over to my mic I would
[ __ ] take that mic away and go like
this I'd say stop and you like don't
grab me like this my microphone get your
own [ __ ] microphone and take off that
stupid [ __ ] what are you wearing
who's that guy who was in The Sopranos
that wears the long [ __ ] thing on his
head
get get at it what are you doing um
anyway yeah dude my [ __ ] life you
know Steven Van Zandt [ __ ] are you
wearing on your head i watch up I say
that he fried cuz you got he I cancer
some [ __ ] and I'm a [ __ ] little
Steven and the disciples of Sol Kok
need to have a band called no that's it
we just wear regular ass [ __ ] and we
[ __ ] sing about how we're the
champions yeah but I get a lot of sleep
on the road dude because you need it if
you do if you sleep you won't get sick
for real and also if you sleep you won't
get sick and then also though this
besides that don't don't
for some reason it's a thing bragging
about how little sleep you get that's so
dumb
dude got four hours of sleep in the last
three days no first of all no you didn't
remember that guy Tyler Shields bragged
about that's a photographer's name right
he's talking about how he didn't sleep
for a month like who the [ __ ] believes
that you die you just go to sleep event
you know what I mean like you just fall
asleep you can't do that you just go
like for 40 days it's it 40 days no
sleep one liar like you you just fall us
you did it you fall asleep you can't not
sleep what two days at the most
usually you fall asleep the second you
get alone you just pass the [ __ ] out
standing up why is it about people
they're just like oh man a guy we can
dose little god knows and the rock does
it - by the way he'll be like god no
sleep got no sleep got four hours of
sleep but back to the gridiron paradise
or the iron paradise think is that be
football the iron paradise and you'd be
like dude get rest bro what are you
doing it for right such for
everything's clickbait dude everything's
clickbait into I mean oh I'm speaking at
clickbait I clicked on the [ __ ] Liam
Neeson article how the [ __ ] how about
that thing where he was like trying to
get the [ __ ] thing or he was like
somebody he knew got raped by a black
guy so he's looking for him or some [ __ ]
I don't know man whatever everything
online is just so remember at the the
Super Bowl thing just right the other
day there was an article Adam Levine's
nipple stole the shaft I'm show what huh
what the [ __ ] are you talking about what
are you [ __ ] for all they did was
take off his shirt if anything is
tattoos he just had regular nipples
nothing was wrong with his nipples and
also how annoying was it when people
were like everyone only likes to talk
[ __ ] about the [ __ ] halftime show
unless if it dude if it was Beyonce
everyone would talk about how great it
was if it if it wasn't be if it isn't
Beyonce which it isn't everybody no
matter who it is everyone's gonna talk
about how bad it was it wasn't bad at
all you doing exactly what [ __ ]
maroon 5 does just dude did I talk about
this like yeah I did talk about this
that if Harrison Ford was around
everyone is like nobody talks [ __ ] to
Adam Levine in person he's a [ __ ]
great singer
nobody talks [ __ ] about him in person
because their [ __ ] asked [ __ ]
and then when they go online they go
like yeah right look at his [ __ ]
stupid tattoos oh yeah okay bro you're
40 what are you doing with your [ __ ] bro
sit you can't nothing you're a you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ] ass [ __ ]
you when Adam Levine walks around and
everyone's aw man big for even people
who aren't fat I'm a big fan kind of get
a picture
you're [ __ ] kiss-ass that's what you
are online if you're talking [ __ ] you're
a kiss
you're a kiss-ass [ __ ] you don't
say they [ __ ] to him in this so if
you're [ __ ] walking around you don't
see it if you look online you see it you
know Adam Levine he'll let us see it but
he's one of the most popular individuals
period
I remember that fake [ __ ] that they did
where they took her nipple out in the
Janet Jackson it's just like it was so
setup the malfunction my [ __ ]
malfunction like it's a robot this is
reveal nipple whoops
whoopsie Daisy oh no my nipple is
revealed
oopsie Daisy back to football kickoff
number two kickoff number two oh yeah
man I don't know what are we at what
time are we at or should we do uh
questions and what do you call it
also misconnections let's do we should
do oh come on dude I mean these
misconnections dude case wait didn't we
do this one Oh another one yeah face
time come this is again face time come
looking for another guy packing big so I
guess it happened already so I got it
good job connection made looking for
another guy packing big that wants to
come together on FaceTime DL one-time
thing sent pic boy is real serious about
the one time thing he's not using the
last guy again do not contact me with
unsolicited services or offers well good
luck to this guy again guy keeps getting
that FaceTime come going nice this is
great Maria worked at Pep Boys years ago
Pasadena oh this is like a haiku this is
like done in a poem it's like each lines
like a stanza each line is new we were
friends we would go out every chance we
had it was kind of contradicting but
okay we would take drives to Santa
Monica after work you had a maroon
Accord if you ever read this contact me
this happened like 1819 years ago Jesus
Christ do not contact me with
unsolicited services or offers yeah well
obviously you just want to talk to Maria
you know like I got like some guys gonna
see that and be like hey man you want to
get [ __ ] in the ass instead probably
Maria dude 19 years ago so that would
say they were in their teens so they
must be 40 50 it could be 30 something
late 30s
40 50 Wow what if they were 50 and now
they're 70 though if you're 70 props to
props for looking at a knowing how to
use the Internet this one is a great
title help with a question mark Van Nuys
any females need help with a bill or
anything willing to trade be serious
send a picture of yourself do not
contact me with unsolicited services or
offers why don't you just go aren't
there like websites for hookers just go
on there just pictures there
what kind of bill are you talking about
to like what you're doing this the wrong
way
go to [ __ ] hookers calm
what is hookers calm in fact what would
hookers dot-com be so obvious if it's
really I should buy hookers calm hooker
calm Hooker Furniture cool hey change
your [ __ ] name hooker furniture you
know hooker furniture like so many oh
here we go
hookers calm you know what came up
ladies experienced hookers experienced
hookers calm comes up oh this is like
fishing hookers are trying to hook her
the fishing the hooks are trying to take
it
take it over trying to take over that
[ __ ] take that word back hookers what
a violent name for someone who sells her
body I'm a hooker all right what else
dad what I mean this title alone dude
you gotta listen to this dad for son I
don't I didn't read this one yet but how
about ask your mom first you know here
we go
I am a very handsome busy successful dad
oh Jesus Christ
looking for son my company requires a
full-time investment of my time I am
looking for a young 18 to 30 year old
cute guy to spend time with I am too
busy a relationship is not a possibility
I want someone who I can call to go to
dinner with or someone who can sleep
over and have some fun I am NOT looking
to govern your life weird choice of
words
I just want romantic company when I have
time to get away I would ideally like
something on on going I am 45 medium
build green eyes six-foot Italian Greek
very handsome is this exact Tonko vo
please send photo with your reply and I
will do the same do not contact with
unsolicited services or offers yeah it's
pretty pretty [ __ ] specific buddy Wow
West Hollywood huh interesting I could
do it hey man I sent a pic of me my
headshot I still from undateable here
you go I'll do it I'll be your son you
want to get dinner and have some crazy
sleepovers oh man I love this title yeah
you deserve it looking for the milf or a
housekeeper girl different that needs a
long wet release using my mouth gross
bro I'm a cool respectful Magette no
you're not
you're not cool or respectful if you're
asking a MILF if she wants a wet release
using a your mouth I'm a cool respectful
mature Latino man who loves to please
nothing expected in return so bad
childhood do not contact me with
unsolicited service or offers looking
for the mill for a housekeeper girl that
needs a wet release using come on guy is
in South Park okay well right to it this
one's come and unload guess how come is
spelled male for male [ __ ]
hosting in WeHo for now I like how this
guy's transient this guy's on the go
right now I'm in we--how if you need to
come and unload BB bottom blindfolded
it's a bad childhood looking for tops oh
we get it
porn playing in background door unlocked
ass in the air stats and body pic for a
dress Wow
BB only what does BB I don't know I
thought I meant baby big black big
beautiful now but that's a stats and
body pics stats you know I had 43 stolen
bases
can I come [ __ ] your ass I had 43 stolen
bases last year with the Oakland
Athletics can I come [ __ ] your ass dude
that's crazy to to to have that that's
crazy to think my my my [ __ ] kink is
I'm gonna blindfold myself put on porn
in the background have my ass in the air
and my door unlocked and you comment
unload Wow whatever whatever floats your
boat you know but but wow wow wow
well hey as long as you're not hurting
anybody right I guess that's it man you
know I got nothing else that was a
[ __ ] wild I was thinking about that
but just remember man that's kind of
Scotland you know nope no nobody knows
about political corruption nobody knows
about dudes all peace and love and you
know you blindfold yourself and wait for
a guy to just stuff it up you know to
just stuff it up gross okay cool well um
I got that new Chicago date added uh
anyway that guy blindfolded him 11
[ __ ] pompous ass I got new Chicago Day
coming up
st. Louis was rescheduled Seattle coming
up soon Hamilton Ontario Windsor Ontario
Kalamazoo Anaheim San eanes Valley
Center Albany Hanover Maryland
Huntington New York Cleveland Columbus
Cincinnati Lexington Albuquerque change
your name Santa Fe Phoenix Tucson
Greensboro Newport News for some reason
anyway uh
follow-the-leader togetic is a crystal a
calm and download the cash app for free
on the App Store or Google Play market
and two rewards code congrats get $5
give $5 - times up download the Chris
D'Elia app you get to see other [ __ ]
this episode you get to see a different
[ __ ] one because we had to start over
because one fire literally didn't hit
the record button for the first eight
minutes one fire a hundred percent
support the show by buying merch at
store Chris D'Elia calm we got new stuff
coming up soon you guys are killing it I
see all you with the wouldn't make a
[ __ ] 10 shirts out there and the baby
shirts the babies merchant tees
subscribe to the YouTube channel they
come out every day after the [ __ ] the
day after the the day after the audio
ones and
you can watch my specials on Netflix you
can go to comedians the world watch a
new one
non-stop or you can watch a man on fire
a lot of people have been watching
incorrigible lately I've been getting a
lot of [ __ ] DMS and tweets about that
so that's very cool I don't know why
that one boy but you guys are great
thanks so much my babies and that's it
you guys had a good time finding
[Music]